entonces tenemos la oportunidad de influir en la cantidad de cambio climático futuro
que vamos a necesitar para adaptarnos.
Así que tenemos una elección.
Podemos optar por empezar a tomar en serio el cambio climático,
y mitigar y reducir significativamente las emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero,
y luego tendremos que adaptarnos a los menores impactos climáticos futuros.
O podemos seguir ignorando el problema del cambio climático.
Pero si hacemos eso, también estamos escogiendo
adaptarnos a impactos muchísimo más potente del clima en el futuro.
Y no solo eso.
Como personas que vivimos en países con altas emisiones per cápita,
estamos haciendo la elección en nombre de los demás.
Pero la elección de que no disponemos
es de un futuro sin cambio climático.
Durante las dos últimas décadas,
nuestros negociadores del Gobierno y los políticos han estado reuniéndose
para discutir el cambio climático,
y han estado enfocados en evitar un calentamiento de 2 grados centígrados
sobre los niveles preindustriales.
Esa es la temperatura que está asociada con impactos peligrosos
a través de una gama de diferentes indicadores,
para los seres humanos y para el medio ambiente.
Así que 2 grados centígrados constituyen un cambio climático peligroso.
Pero el cambio peligroso puede ser subjetivo.
Así que si pensamos en un evento extremo
que podría suceder en alguna parte del mundo,
y ocurre en una parte del mundo donde hay una buena infraestructura,
donde hay personas que están bien aseguradas y así,
entonces ese impacto puede ser perjudicial.
Puede causar malestar, podría generar costos.
Incluso algunas muertes.
Pero si ese mismo evento pasa en una parte del mundo
donde hay infraestructura deficiente,
o donde las personas no están bien aseguradas,
o no tienen buenas redes de apoyo,
ese mismo impacto del cambio climático podría ser devastador.
Podría causar una pérdida significativa de viviendas,
y también podría causar cantidades significativas de muertos.
Este es un gráfico de las emisiones de CO2 en el lado izquierdo
a partir de combustibles fósiles y la industria,
y el tiempo antes de la Revolución Industrial
hasta el día de hoy.
Y lo que inmediatamente llama la atención aquí
es que las emisiones han crecido de manera exponencial.
Si nos centramos en un período más corto, a partir de 1950,
establecimos en 1988
el Grupo Intergubernamental de Expertos sobre el Cambio Climático,
la Cumbre de la Tierra de Río en 1992,
luego yendo unos pocos años, en 2009 tuvimos el Acuerdo de Copenhague,
donde se estableció evitar un aumento de temperatura de 2 grados
en consonancia con la ciencia y sobre la base de la equidad.
Y luego, en 2012, tuvimos el evento Río + 20.
Y todo este camino, durante todas estas reuniones
y muchas otras más,
y las emisiones han seguido aumentando.
Si nos centramos en la tendencia histórica de emisiones en los últimos años,
y ponemos que junto a nuestra comprensión
del sentido de la marcha en nuestra economía global,
entonces estamos mucho más en el camino
para un cambio de 4 grados centígrados del calentamiento global
de lo que estamos para el de 2 grados centígrados.
Vamos a hacer una pausa un momento
y pensar en esto de 4 grados en la temperatura media global.
La mayor parte de nuestro planeta es en realidad mar.
Debido a que el mar tiene una mayor inercia térmica que la tierra,
las temperaturas medias por la tierra son en realidad mayores
que las del mar.
La segunda cosa es que como seres humanos no experimentamos
las temperaturas medias globales.
Experimentamos los días de calor, los días fríos,
los días de lluvia, sobre todo si viven en Manchester como yo.
Pónganse en el centro de la ciudad.
Imaginen un lugar en el mundo:
Mumbai, Pekín, Nueva York, Londres.
Es el día más caluroso que alguna vez han experimentado.
El sol caía
hay concreto y cristal a su alrededor.
Ahora imaginen que ese mismo día,
pero 6, 8 o tal vez de 10 a 12 grados más caliente
en ese día durante la ola de calor.
Ese es el tipo de cosas que vamos a experimentar
en un escenario de la temperatura media global de 4 grados.
Y el problema con estos extremos,
y no solo con las temperaturas extremas,
sino también los extremos en términos de tormentas y otros impactos climáticos,
es que nuestra infraestructura simplemente no se creó para enfrentar estos eventos.
Nuestros caminos y redes ferroviarias
han sido diseñados para durar largo tiempo
y soportar solo ciertos impactos
en diferentes partes del mundo.
Y esto va a ser muy retado.
Se espera que nuestros centrales eléctricas sean enfriadas con agua
a una temperatura determinada para seguir siendo eficaces y resistentes.
Nuestros edificios están diseñados para ser cómodos
dentro de un intervalo de temperatura.
Y todo esto va a ser cuestionado de manera significativa
bajo un escenario de tipo de 4 grados.
Nuestra infraestructura no ha sido diseñada para hacer frente a esto.
Remontémonos, también pensando en unos cuatro grados,
no son solo en los impactos directos,
sino también algunos impactos indirectos.
Si tomamos la seguridad alimentaria, por ejemplo.
Los rendimientos del maíz y el trigo
en algunas partes del mundo
se espera que sean hasta un 40 % más bajos
en un escenario de 4 grados,
arroz hasta un 30 % menor.
Esto será absolutamente devastador para la seguridad alimentaria mundial.
Así que en general, los tipos de impactos anticipados
bajo este escenario de 4 grados centígrados
van a ser incompatibles con la vida organizada global.
De vuelta a nuestras trayectorias y nuestros gráficos de 4 grados y 2 grados.
¿Es razonable aún a concentrarse en el camino de los 2 grados?
Hay bastantes de mis colegas y otros científicos
que dirían que ya es muy tarde para evitar un calentamiento de 2 grados.
Pero me gustaría dibujar mi propia investigación
en sistemas de energía, en sistemas alimentarios,
aviación y también navegación,
solo para decir que creo que todavía hay una pequeña oportunidad de luchar
de evitar el peligro de 2 grados de cambio climático.
Pero necesitamos familiarizarnos con los números
para encontrar cómo hacerlo.
Si se centran en esta trayectoria y estos gráficos,
el círculo amarillo allí destaca que la partida
de la vía de 4 grados roja
a vía verde de los 2 grados es inmediata.
Y eso es debido a las emisiones acumulativas,
o el presupuesto de carbono.
En otras palabras, a causa de las luces y los proyectores
que están en este salón ahora mismo,
el CO2 que está yendo a nuestra atmósfera
como resultado de que el consumo de electricidad
dura un tiempo muy largo.
Algunos estarán en nuestra atmósfera un siglo, tal vez mucho más tiempo.
Se acumularán y los gases de efecto invernadero tienden a acumularse.
Y eso nos dice algo acerca de estas trayectorias.
En primer lugar, nos dice que es el área bajo estas curvas lo que importa,
no donde se llega en una fecha determinada en el futuro.
Y eso es importante, porque no importa
si encontramos alguna increíble tecnología, ¡plum!,
para solucionar nuestro problema energético el último día de 2049,
justo a tiempo para arreglar las cosas.
Porque mientras tanto, las emisiones se han acumulado.
Así que si seguimos en esta roja, de 4 grados centígrados,
cuanto más tiempo continuamos en ella,
más tendrá que ser compensado en años posteriores
para el mismo presupuesto de carbono, para tener la misma área bajo la curva,
lo que significa que esa trayectoria, roja allí, se hace más pronunciada.
En otras palabras, si no reducimos las emisiones en el corto y mediano plazo,
vamos a tener que hacer reducciones más significativas de año en año.
Sabemos que tenemos que descarbonizar nuestro sistema energético.
Pero si no empezamos a reducir las emisiones en el corto y mediano plazo,
entonces vamos a tener que hacer eso incluso antes.
Así que esto plantea realmente grandes desafíos para nosotros.
La otro es que nos dice algo acerca de la política energética.
Si viven en una parte del mundo donde las emisiones per cápita ya son altas,
nos orienta hacia la reducción de la demanda de energía.
Y esto porque con toda la voluntad del mundo,
la infraestructura de ingeniería a gran escala
que tenemos que desplegar rápidamente
para descarbonizar la oferta de nuestro sistema energético
simplemente no va a darse a tiempo.
Así que no importa si elegimos la energía nuclear
o la captura y almacenamiento de carbono,
aumentamos la producción de biocombustibles,
o ir a un mayor despliegue de turbinas de viento y turbinas de onda.
Todo eso llevará tiempo.
Así que como es el área bajo la curva lo que importa,
tenemos que centrarnos en la eficiencia energética,
y también en la conservación de energía en otras palabras, el uso de menos energía.
Y si lo hacemos, eso también significa
que a medida que seguimos lanzando la tecnología de oferta,
tendremos menos que hacer si no nos hemos arreglado
para reducir nuestro consumo de energía,
porque vamos a tener menos infraestructura en el lado de la oferta.
Otro tema con el que realmente tenemos que lidiar con
es el tema de bienestar y equidad.
Hay muchas partes del mundo donde el nivel de vida tiene que subir.
Pero con sistemas de energía de combustibles fósiles,
a medida que crecen las economías también lo harán las emisiones.
Si todos estamos limitados por el mismo presupuesto de carbono,
entonces si en algunas partes del mundo están necesitando subir,
entonces en otras partes las emisiones mundiales deben reducirse.
Esto plantea retos muy importantes para los países ricos.
Porque de acuerdo con nuestra investigación,
si estás en un país donde las emisiones per cápita son muy altas,
América del Norte, Europa, Australia,
la reducción de emisiones del orden del 10 % al año,
a partir de ahora son necesarias para tener buena oportunidad
de evitar la meta de los 2 grados.
Permítanme poner esto en contexto.
El economista Nicholas Stern
dijo que las reducciones de emisiones de más de 1 % por año
solo se habían asociado siempre con recesión económica o agitación.
Así que esto plantea enormes desafíos para la tema del crecimiento económico,
porque al tener nuestra infraestructura de alto carbono en su lugar,
significa que si crecen nuestras economías,
entonces también lo harán nuestras emisiones.
Solo me gustaría citar un documento
de Kevin Anderson y mío de 2011
donde dijimos que para evitar el el peligroso cambio de 2 grados,
el crecimiento económico tendría que ser cambiado al menos temporalmente
por un período de austeridad en las naciones ricas.
Este es un mensaje muy difícil de tomar,
porque sugiere es que realmente tenemos que hacer las cosas de manera diferente.
No es un cambio incremental.
Se trata de hacer las cosas de manera diferente, cambiar todo el sistema,
y, a veces se trata de hacer menos cosas.
Y esto se aplica a todos nosotros,
cualquiera que sea la esfera de influencia que tengamos.
Podría ser escribir a nuestro político local
hablar con nuestro jefe en el trabajo o ser el jefe en el trabajo,
o hablar con amigos y familiares, o, simplemente, cambiar nuestro estilo de vida.
Porque realmente tenemos que hacer un cambio significativo.
Por el momento, estamos eligiendo un escenario de 4 grados.
Si realmente queremos evitar el escenario de 2 grados,
realmente no hay mejor momento que el presente para actuar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Alice, lo que estás diciendo,
es que a menos que los países ricos empiezan cortar el 10 % al año
las emisiones ya, este año, no en 2020 o 25,
vamos a ir directamente a la situación de más 4 grados.
Me pregunto cuál es su opinión sobre el corte en un 70 % para 2070.
Alice Bows-Larkin: Sí, es justo algo así para evitar 2 grados.
Una de las cosas que a menudo...
cuando hay estos estudios de modelos en que se ve lo que tenemos que hacer,
se tiende a sobrestimar enormemente la rapidez con que otros países en el mundo
pueden empezar a reducir las emisiones.
Así hacen tipo de supuestos heroicos sobre eso.
Cuanto más lo hacemos, porque son las emisiones acumuladas,
el corto plazo es el que realmente importa.
Hace una gran diferencia.
Si un gran país como China, por ejemplo,
sigue creciendo, incluso por unos pocos años más,
hará una gran diferencia para cuando tengamos que descarbonizar.
No creo que ni siquiera podamos decir cuándo va a ser,
ya que depende de lo que tenemos que hacer en el corto plazo.
Pero creo que tenemos gran alcance, y no tiramos de esas palancas
que permitirán reducir la demanda de energía, lo que es una pena.
BG: Alice, gracias por venir a TED y compartir estos datos.
ABL: Gracias.
(Aplausos)